man in the United States illegally has
been charged with the murder of Molly
Tibbets Matt Finn has the latest Matt
just a tragic ending to this mystery
nearly a month after Molly Tibbets
vanished on July 18th police a short
while telling us that 24-year old
Christian Rivera was just charged with
first degree murder in the death of
Molly Tibbets investigators tell us that
there was a surveillance tape that was
crucial in solving this mystery and this
crime a surveillance tape that showed
Molly Tibbets apparently running they
looked at that surveillance tape and
apparently saw Christian Rivera in his
car or somewhere on that tape they say
that they questioned Rivera about the
death of Molly Tibbets he says that on
the evening she went missing on July
18th he was following her we're not sure
if he followed her first in his car or
on foot and that he eventually started
to chase her and Molly Tibbets said get
away from me she got out her cellphone
and asked him to get away from her he
tells police at that point he blacked
out then this morning nearly more than a
month later this man took authorities to
the body of Molly Tibbets which is not
far from here it was found in a
cornfield apparently trying to be hidden
by some extra corn stalks investigators
say that that man has been charged with
first-degree murder and we are expecting
to learn much more as this story
develops Matt could I ask you something
I know you've been covering this case
from the beginning early on when the
police had a press conference they said
at one point that they believed that the
suspect was hiding in plain sight do you
think that Christian Rivera was that
person well we're told that he lived in
this area for four to seven years so he
was perhaps a member of this community
maybe a well-known member of this
community so it is very likely Dana that
he was hiding in plain sight authorities
and family said that they think there's
a possibility that the person
contributed to the search efforts we
can't confirm that we don't know for
Vera was hiding out the entire time or
if he was going on with his daily life
Dana Gregg has a question probably I was
it's a dumb question but he's legal
alien here for four to seven years how
did he pull that off was it
one of those cases where no one need him
to check yeah not sure Greg it's a good
question
I want anybody questions you know one of
the interesting things about this is
that her cell phone and her Fitbit had
been reported as missing and I wonder if
they have now recovered those items and
if that could help although it seems as
if we have a confession in this case I
believe that at the tail end of this
press conference that just wrapped up
one of the lead investigators did say
that her Fitbit did help she also had
her iPhone on her and what's interesting
is that investigators were out in this
area for quite some time and they were
questioning a farmer who lived nearby
multiple times and that farmer confessed
or insisted that he had nothing to do
with this so we're trying to now confirm
if investigators were out here because
maybe her Fitbit did ping out here maybe
her cellphone
did ping out in the region where her
body was found all right mat fan thank
you thanks for all of your reporting on
this story